the former student accused of one of
america's deadliest school shootings is
expected to plead guilty today to murder
and attempted murder charges prosecutors
say nicholas cruz killed 14 students and
three staffers at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in parkland florida
a jury will then decide whether to
sentence cruz to death or life in prison
maria viral is outside the courthouse in
fort lauderdale maria good morning
hey good morning tony right now nicholas
cruz's decision to change his plea to
guilty definitely surprise a lot of
people but one of the fathers i spoke
with of jamie gutenberg one of the
victims says today's plea will only be
meaningful to him if the shooter
inevitably pays with his life
the past three years have been
torture for fred gutenberg nicholas
cruz's anticipated guilty plea is
another step along a painful road
i dreamt
every day of walking my daughter down
the aisle
and because of what this murderer did
i now live every day knowing i won't get
to do that his daughter jamie was a
dancer and had her entire life planned
at age 14. but on valentine's day 2018
those plans were destroyed
the then 19-year-old former student
nicholas cruz walked into stoneman
douglas with an ar-15 style rifle and
began shooting 17 people dead 17 others
injured and countless more suffering
from the trauma from that day
defense attorneys will likely argue that
cruz's history of mental illness is
reason to spare his life a jury must be
unanimous to sentence him to death
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemen the
prosecution is going to go straight for
the death penalty in this case and well
they should they're going to show that
the case was one of premeditated murder
knowing intentional murder with planning
it was atrocious it was cruel it was
heinous so the prosecution is going into
this with all the cards in the hand for
fred gutenberg
justice is clear
my daughter should be living the best
years of her life
my son heard his sister get shot and his
life is forever impacted
my wife and i
had two children that killer took this
from us
and i want that killer to pay for this
with his life
the sentencing part of this trial has
yet to be said it's a little complicated
here in florida for capital punishment
cases a completely new trial has to come
on and one of the hurdles that attorneys
will face is actually finding enough
jurors to sit on that particular part of
the trial
who are okay with giving cruz the
punishment of death if they believe he
deserves it even if they personally do
not believe in it once they give that
decision to a judge he gives the final
stamp of approval so as of right now it
is a very clear that uh cruz's fate is
unclear nate
thank you
my heart hurts for those families yes
you can understand and feel the father's
pain and i think many people thought
after parkland maybe things would change
in this country when you look at mr cruz
he's so small and has caused so much
damage yeah i don't know what it's going
to take for us to really get
the damage that is called and the pain
that still continues when you have an
incident like that it doesn't matter how
small you are if you're carrying a
powerful no it doesn't yeah that's
that's the point i i yeah that's exactly
right when we're reminded of these
incidents and seeing the trial we know
that these parents and these family
members have to relive it during the
trial but we forget this is an everyday
battle it's never over for them when it
comes to those type of losses
our thoughts are with those families for
sure